where are we headed medieval setting a
course in the year 507 you do the
jealous squat you to Camelot come on
isn't about history people just first
it's about one noble idea but we must
rise you ready to go get medieval out
there
DC's legends of tomorrow all new Tuesday
February 21st on the CW
youtubers is Charlie this is gonna be my
legends of tomorrow episode 12 trailer
video in episode 11 Easter Egg video
combined careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet so
because there's so much DC and Marvel
stuff happening I'm gonna combine this
so I don't have to do like 50 videos
this week so this is the trailer for
Camelot 3000 which is this really weird
arc from the comics that I'll explain
and my episode video from this week
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so just a teaser for the
Camelot episode that the Camelot 3000
storyline in the comics was this really
weird run where it's this reincarnated
version of the knights of the round
table King Arthur that reemerge in the
year 3000 so it was part of DC's
continuity it was meant to be this
really weird trippy story now they're
having a lot of fun with it in the
legends of tomorrow universe you can see
that there's just a society members that
are coming back to I'll explain more
about that at the end of the video but
we have to talk about that heatwave
intro to this past episode he killed it
who writes this crap anyway seriously
you idiot something figured this out by
now it all started when we blow up the
time takes the time masters now history
is all screwed up and it's up to us to
unscrew it up but after time we screw
things up people
so don't call the zero who's for
something else
we're legends who writes this crap
anyway the best thing about legends of
tomorrow is that if you thought the
flash was really fun and silly legends
of tomorrow this season has just taken
that ball and completely spiked it in
the endzone this is so much better so
you can see how it kind of fits in with
the other DC TV shows it's meant to be
this really big fun epic swashbuckling
drama across space and time we'll have
to talk about it more at the end of the
season because I think what'll end up
happening is is that when arrow
eventually goes off the air if they
don't have another show that's gonna
take its place they'll move legends to
Wednesday night and it'll be a Supergirl
flash in legends and then after that who
knows because they have the Black
Lightning TV show that's coming let's do
top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs I
already talked about the heat wave intro
that was really my number 10 heat wave
in the Legion of Doom
intro were my favorite intros of the
season so far there's one episode that I
think might beat it in it's called doom
world it's the last episode before the
finale and I cannot wait to hear what
the intro for that is because it makes
it seem like the Legion of Doom has
constructed the spear of destiny
they rewrite history and the legends
have to deal with their version of
flashpoint and try to fix everything
rewrite reality back to what it should
be number nine was evil rip hunter
killing George Washington than just
casually like almost like he was having
fun giving all those weapons to the
British soldiers telling them how much
fun it was gonna be to rewrite history
in play dirty so number eight enter the
reverse-flash I know he's still not
wearing the costume he actually posted
this picture from a future episode that
they're filming right now with him back
in the yellow costume so there'll be
plenty more reverse-flash stuff
happening in future episodes there's
eobard thawne's stuff
then there's reverse-flash stuff but
because of what he did to rip hunter's
memories for whatever reason now he is
just completely aligned with the Legion
of Doom he feels nothing for the legends
so maybe he erased some of those
memories it seems like his motivation
mostly flows from the time masters
allowing his children to die at the
hands of Vandal Savage in for some
reason whatever memories got rewritten
he didn't get over that so that's why
he's with the Legion of Doom number
seven was the big giant rat
all back so early in the episode Adam
has complained to heatwave dude you eat
food everywhere and he does he's like
Brad Pitt he's got food in his mouth in
every single scene so he complains that
there's a rat on board the Waverider
that later they bring back after he gets
stuck being tiny running from the giant
rat which he then later gives to
heatwave as a Christmas gift so I loved
some of the pairings in this episode now
obviously there was the big pairing
number 6 vixen and citizen Steele
totally getting it on him explaining
tinder her explaining how she never got
to see the end of Wizard of Oz so he
gives her the ruby slippers but plot
aside just a lot of the funny moments
that they had together were great in
this episode like him going over the
falls her calling the seal totem then at
the end of the episode she just
basically tells them dude chill there's
not gonna be any relationship stuff
happening here which i think is great I
love that people are actually allowed to
have sex without being in relationships
on this TV show number 5 was all the
craziness on the Waverider
there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
damn it I'm a physicist not a doctor so
this is really Jax's episode to step up
it was him versus rip hunter sort of
confronted with the idea that maybe you
can't save some people like he almost
kills him but Sarah stops him because
she doesn't want him to lose a part of
his soul all the Sarah dying jokes were
great I died once didn't like it too
much just making a joke about the
Lazarus Pit on arrow she kind of died
two more times in this episode number
four was heatwave in General Washington
they were great together you don't know
what it means to be a real American
he basically gives in the business and
by the end of the episode Washington is
like a gentlemen would fight but I'm an
American so let's run so now because of
that because they're bros he totally has
a statue of himself in Washington DC
that's still there in present day so he
is now one of America's founding fathers
it is so great jokes like that or why I
love this show so much number three was
evil rip hunter killing Sara again just
being super vicious he was nuts when he
was on the Waverider
trying to get that spear fragment from
Jax you see him pause for a minute when
he's getting ready to kill Sara like
he's thinking about it but then just
says he feels nothing so it's definitely
not an act he's been completely
rewritten
as a human being which is why he has his
old accent back all of his old memories
with the exception of the ones that made
him a good person so the key to fixing
him is getting that memory matrix that
the reverse-flash stole from the bank
fault so if they can get that back they
can rewrite his memories to what they
should be but number two was the
Christmas dinner I totally love scenes
like this it was kind of a downer
episode because somebody that you're
supposed to trust this rip hunter figure
is now totally evil so we got really
hardcore really fast but they find a way
to make you feel a little bit better
they're like the Legion of Doom has the
spear fragment but they don't have this
family that's gonna be important for
later episodes because even though the
Legion came to an agreement at the end
of last week's episode where the
reverse-flash is like okay finally we're
all partners they will still eat each
other alive that's just in their nature
they don't have the friendship the
camaraderie that the legends have which
is what that scene was all about number
1 is the return of the Justice Society
in the Camelot episode in two weeks so
as you saw that star girl in the
background the way they explained this
is that the remaining spear fragments of
the spear of destiny are held by
different Justice Society members that
are hidden across space and time so this
spear fragment is with star girl in this
Camelot 3000 time period so like I said
the storyline from the comics that this
is based on was the resurrected knights
of the round table King Arthur Guinevere
in the year 3000 so it'll be fun to see
how they addressed the idea of them
being mythical figures from history
versus a real people citizen Steele is
the real historian so he'll probably
have some things to say about that like
King Arthur was he an actual real person
or was he just somebody that was made up
so just remember this is the comics so
sometimes they make fictional people
real in the world of the comics the
legends of tomorrow Game of Thrones in
two weeks so just a reminder that the
flash is on break arrows gonna be on
break two legends of tomorrow so all the
DC shows will be on break next week then
they'll come back the week after that
but I will be doing bonus videos for
everything in the video schedule today
is going to be iron fist footage there's
some new footage I'll post later tonight
then I'll post my Legion episode 1 video
Thursday morning then I'll post my arrow
video
congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner luke Rizzo
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I saw you're also
subscribed to my gaming channel of
Charlie's Dreams if you guys didn't know
I do have a game channel I don't post
there that often just because all these
normal videos take up my time so much
but I might stream there later
there's always links for that in the
description if you want to find out
where the other channels I have are and
I got some new really cool iron fists
that I'll post later tonight and then
I'll update everybody on the video
schedule on Twitter and Facebook as I
post new videos while you wait for that
to post you can click here for my flash
episode and you can click here for the
trailer for the next episode of flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you in the next
video